honey about the day so let me talk about
the day this is when I was in college it
was my senior year going to Baylor
University in Texas yeah I senior let me
by myself in in an apartment and people
kind of knew my apartment I've been
doing the ventriloquism forever
in fact my license plate actually said
dummy on my car so people do yeah so my
apartment got all the latest well I
admit that what I do for a living is not
normal and I get it I don't know how I
got the wife I have are driving married
for seven years now and she's beautiful
and it works it's fantastic yeah but
that's okay but never in the history of
the planet has any woman ever said
ventriloquist
that's hot I do know that I never heard
it they never said it to me let me get
to the story so I've been dating this
girl in my apartment was covered with
dummies they were at my collection of
dummies I'm not getting rid of my damn
dummies because I didn't bring me joy
okay so I like my clutter of dolls all
right so anyway so the dummies are all
lined up in the main room the first room
you walk in in the apartment they're all
lined up and sitting on the walls it's
kind of creepy where you are okay but it
was my thing and I built them and I
collected them they're antiques it was
just weird and people actually said to
me yeah you got to go to Jeff Dunham's
apartment that's a thing anyway so this
girl I had only taken her out like three
or four times so it was kind of you know
we're getting close right so I brought
her over to the apartment and we're
sitting on the couch and I had secretly
this is the thing that's going to come
out the tape is there I had secretly put
a VHS recorder this was in the 80s in
the corner and hid I hid the camera
amongst the dummies and it was shooting
the couch okay so here I am James
Taylor's playing of course yeah yep so
and we're getting kind of romantic and
the tape is going and I did this for one
reason only I wanted to see her reaction
when the dummy that was in the
corner that I had secretly
radio-controlled moved when I wasn't
looking and she was yeah yeah so this is
a female audience going
oh you're horrible but no you sound like
my husband he likes to scare people but
it's the greatest type ever because here
it is I'm sitting there with her like
this and I'm looking over the other way
and I had the radio-control under a
pillow over here so I moved it and that
don't moved his head's in his eyes just
like this and she's like oh great Texas
accent she's like oh my god I'm like
that dummy just moved his head and I'm
like no it didn't she goes it did I just
saw a move I'm like yeah everybody says
that it is fine to do so we get another
five minutes pass and it moves his eyes
and his head against yeah that's what
she did she's out the doors he's gone
I'm like I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this